all right settle please
this is it bobby all right here we go
roll camera i don't uh what am i doing
i'll do my thing and i'll go huh you
just react okay
what the you need your phone uh phone's
supposed to be in your hand
scare you yeah sorry about that let's do
it here we go
i'm gonna vomit power things up line it
up
speeding rolling here we go this is for
real bobby will do the jump
and action
[Music]
nice job yeah bobby one take wonder over
here
yeah i'm glad they liked it but that
hurt
in training i learned to keep my chin
down and body flat
but i didn't do that on set and i paid
the price
now i know it ain't easy but the
successful stunts are the ones you can
walk away from appreciate that
appreciate that bobby you're good yeah
the fall was the thing i was most afraid
of all right
now down to your final f and that is
fire all right bobby in position
but the burn is the thing that i think
is the most dangerous
i have a molotov cocktail that i will
drop into position
and that will ignite your arm are you
ready
is anyone really ready to ever be set on
fire
all right are you all set johnny you
ready yes sir okay light the mountaintop
you need this right here right here we
go
everything in my mind is saying this is
insane
ah calm down
there you go give me his face wait wait
go back to the fire are you okay yep
the hardest part about that is letting
it burn
and not reacting to it you did a good
job thank you
feel good all right bobby just one more
i'm kidding that was great we got it we
totally got it oh my goodness
nice job man you really did good thank
you i was pretty proud of myself
i felt like i handled that pretty well
[Music]
you